[Music]
never mind it's one of the biggest
moments of her career it's all exciting
and surreal
Halle Bailey wants to kiss a real-life
Prince
[Music]
that's the newest Disney princess
running into the arms of boyfriend ddg
after weeks of The Little Mermaids media
blitz around the world as Hallie puts it
in the caption on my last day of press
like
we can imagine Hallie's fans might be
happy too enjoying a rare look at the
star's relationship with the 25 year old
rapper
yeah the couple who confirmed they were
dating last year keeps their romance
pretty low-key do you have time for
romance yeah yeah you know we gotta make
time for that
it's something that Hallie opened up
about this week to glamor telling the
mag that she knows a lot of people still
see her as a young girl it's very
overwhelming and I get really emotional
when talking about it but the 23 year
old actress reminds everyone I'm able to
make my own decisions
and for her peace and Sanity Hallie will
continue to keep her personal life
private
I want to be where the people are but on
the flip side a topic Halley's thrilled
to talk about her groundbreaking role as
Ariel in The Little Mermaid
I know you have had to see these videos
that we've all been seeing of these
little girls especially these little
black girl seeing you seeing your image
and how they react to just seeing you
what has that been like for you it's
been such a beautiful moment for me to
be able to see the reactions of the
babies it makes me just emotionally
overwhelmed honestly and I cry as soon
as I watch them
[Music]
it feels absolutely amazing to
officially be a Disney princess you have
Daydreams of pretending to be a
cinderella-like you know princess or
someone like that and you never think
like it would actually happen well if
Hallie wasn't inspiring enough I am on
my husband she's also proving she can
live out a real-life fairy tale on her
own terms
foreign